what is going on everybody and welcome
to the setup of your jets and Tegra k1
dev kits the first thing you're gonna
want to do is boot this thing up when
you get out of the box so to start I
guess the most friendly thing to do
would be to go to some sort of a desktop
so to begin that the first thing we're
gonna want to do is actually turn this
thing on now pull over my camera now if
we look at our Jetson take our k1 dev
kit here it is the power is going to be
plugged in right here and then we also
have an HDMI slot right there so I'm
gonna go ahead and plug those things in
and we'll boot it up on one of these
other monitors now I will just say
eventually it will remote desktop and
also use SSH and I can use a pretty
screen recorder for that but until we
get everything fully set up I can't do
that so I'll have to put the webcam over
here and I'll just have to stare at the
screen for a little bit but hopefully it
won't be too big of a deal so anyways
what we're gonna go ahead and do is plug
this in so I'm gonna plug in the HDMI
and plug in the power now before we get
started I suppose it would be helpful to
explain just a couple of these buttons
down here at the bottom if you look at
your quick setup manual that they gave
you they're there but otherwise you can
look at this so this is your board okay
and this button here is your power
button this button is your reset button
and this button is your force recovery
button okay so emergency okay
I'm frozen and please turn off basically
so so those are those and anyway now
I've got this plugged in mh2 now I plug
in the power now and let me situate the
camera so it's facing the screen that
will come up on
all right hopefully that'll be good
enough so now I'll go ahead and plug it
in the dev kit now and as soon as you
plug it in Fanta starts spinning and you
should have a green LED light you'll
start seeing all this stuff whizzing by
alright so interest a login screen one
thing you're going to need is a USB
keyboard once you have that the username
and password is both a boom - so boom -
and - I might mistake that yeah okay
once you've done that you'll want to be
in your home directory for sure but we
are by default and if you want to check
just do LS make sure you've got Nvidia
installer we're going to want to do is
change directory into the Nvidia
installer so CD into and now once you're
there what we're going to want to do is
we're going to run this installation
script which is going to extract them
install the Linux driver binary release
for us so we're gonna go ahead and run
sudo dot forward slash installer dot s H
password and you should have it start
extracting stuff now
and whenever this is all done all you'll
need to do is reboot and that should
have a desktop come up this time so it
would be similar to like start X on your
Raspberry Pi ok
all right so now that that's all done
I'm guessing we can just do sudo compute
that reboots us you probably could have
also used the reset switch
all that stuff flies by
and up pops you're a boon to desktop so
now you've got a nice graphical desktop
now the only problem is I only have this
single USB slot so we only have the
capability for now of my USB keyboard or
my mouse now a couple of things one I
didn't really buy this to go to a
desktop at all so that's not really the
biggest deal but also you see we can
also just SSH into this right and we can
also probably do a remote desktop and so
besides those the other thing too is you
can they make USB splitters so we could
do something like that as well so
anyways that's the bare basics to
getting your Taker k1 dedicate set up
and to your desktop so many other topics
so we're going to be covering is remote
access to it both by SSH and then also
by a remote desktop so you can actually
see this exact desktop also again you
can just get a splitter so anyways if
you guys have any questions or comments
feel free to leave those below as always
thanks for watching things for all the
support in the subscriptions and until
next time